Uh, yes. Let me tell you this story. Since I cliffhanger last time,
uh, when I myself at this all grand dude,
I actually didn't actually didn't cause I told the Freddy Cruz story twice in
this podcast already where the, where I, I, I,
I took a dump in my red shorts at Chris Siegel's house because I was scared
because Freddie was going to get me, dude. I was at,
uh, I went to go to
my cousin's bar mitzvah.
He's like the only Jewish kid in our family. So I felt like I should go.
I want it to support him. My family was there, flew to New York.
The bar mitzvah was in New Jersey,
flew to New York because I was on the road already.
And I was going to meet my, remember I was married,
my ex wife. I was like 20 six. I was going to meet her there. Uh,
and I was staying at the Soho grand for one night before she got there or
something. And anyway, I felt good. You know,
married guy out on the town, got to New York, early, nothing to do.
I was on the road.
Didn't have a show that night woke up early feeling good, dude.
You know, when you're jet lagged,
you go from West to East and you wake up early or, or,
or if you go East to West to wake up early, whatever it is, you know,
you're all up. I went from West to East. I woke up early. I was like,
you know what? I got enough sleep. I'm fine. Let's do this. Get up.
I'm just going to walk around. I went to college here for a year.
So I was going to walk around and look at the area. Hadn't been there for a bit.
Uh, I'm feeling good.
It was one of those times where you wake up and you're just like, you know,
you wake up sometimes. And just so
I see a few blocks down, one of those bagel place,
like those like carts that sell bagels and eggs and bacon and.
And I go one, please
eat it. Keep walking as I'm walking to meet in it.
I see another cart coffee. Hey, look, it's got cool coffees.
Maybe it was a, actually it was like one of those bud.
They are like a little half store. And I say one, please.
No, I'm eating the bagel and I'm drinking the coffee and I'm,
and I'm walking and I'm taking a walk and it's, it's still early.
The streets aren't even bustling yet, but the sun is out now.
I'm keep walking.
I took my last but last sip of coffee and I feel
real hole on the top of my stomach. Now that's fine.
Sometimes your stomach just goes on. All right.
But I keep walking because there's nothing. If I need,
I can go to the bathroom in one of these places, it's all good. Keep walking.
And all of a sudden,
I feel now the first time I felt rule the second time I felt
roll, roll, roll, roll. There were double ROS. Okay. It was like,
Oh man, maybe I should go to the bathroom. Nah, kept walking.
Okay. Also there's bathrooms everywhere.
It's New York city. So now I'm like, ah, you know what?
I actually don't really know what's up.
And my stomach doesn't really feel too well. So I'm like,
I'm just going to turn around what they were going to do in any way. You know,
I'm just going to walk back. Where am I going? I'm just chilling.
I'm just going to walk back. So I start to walk back.
And as soon as I pivot to walk back, I feel [inaudible] rural or, or,
or that's much longer than the first one. So I think, well, I know what I'll do.
I obviously I've got to go to the bathroom. I'll walk back to the hotel.
I'll go back. I'll go to the bathroom at the hotel.
And if I need to I'll stop before that in one of these great,
fantastic shops that exist in New York city.
So I'm walking and walking and the contractions are happening,
you know, closer together. I'm walking,
taking a few steps pretty soon. That
turns into a little bit of a hello. Oh,
okay. I'm like, ah, well, you know what?
I'm actually going to try and find a spot to just unload.
You know what I mean?
So I try to get into this one place. It's close. I'm like, whatever. Oh.
I see it's closed. Oh, all right. Well, it. Keep walking, keep walking.
And I realized that this is where I get mad because it's New York city.
Nothing's open. It's too early, but it's New York city though, dude.
So in my head, not only is law going on, but also I'm like, dude, this is newer.
I'm going to have a look at this New York city.
And none of these places are open. It's 8:00 AM.
Why are none of these places open? I gotta unload.
So now I'm like,
well at least I have the hotel I can get back to. And I'm I start thinking, man,
is this too far away? Dude is my going to give out?
Or the Levy's going to break?
Okay.
So I start walking fast
and now I'm like, where's the place I got to go.
I'm like,
do I go slow enough to check and see if places are open or
do I hit a full sprint and just hope to get back to the hotel. And I don't know.
So I check one more place. It's closed. And that's when I decide Chris,
it's going to be the hotel. You understand? And I hit a full splint sprint.
I hit a full sprint back to the Soho grand and I'm far from it.
And I'm getting, and there are times too where I'm like, Holy.
I don't know if I'm going to make it. I'm clenching so hard.
I get to the soul grant. As soon as I see the Soho grand machine, it starts to,
I start to open up. I'm like, Oh, this is not going to be good. Okay.
I think the hotel elevator better beyond the
floor that I'm on because if I have to wait for it, oopsy, Daisy.
Okay. So I get to the elevator,
the doors open. I don't even hit it. I'm like, thank God people are in it.
They get out. I get on, I hit the button
as I'm going up in the elevator to my floor. I'm unbuckling my pants.
I can't, I can't spare any second. All right.
The door opens and my, my underwear is that I'm I'm if someone's there,
I don't give a. You know, imagine someone at the door open all of a sudden,
I just wanna move Rob and just all over everywhere. That'd be amazing for them,
for them to tell that story. Anyway, I run down the hall to,
I get my key out. I'm running down, holding my pants. I unlock the door.
Now this is the part dude.
There's in the room.
There's a hallway to the bedroom that goes to the right
past this like final four foot hallway is the
bathroom door. Okay. Now, if I'm looking at the, if I'm open,
if I'm opening the bathroom door or if I'm opening the hotel door,
there's the hallway. I have to step through that. That goes, uh,
uh, perpendicular to the where I, how I'm facing.
I don't have to run down the hallway. I have to cross all the way.
You see what I'm saying? And then there's the bathroom.
And the bathroom is set up to where the toilet is to the, if I'm looking at it,
the toilets on the left and it's facing out towards the right. Okay.
So picture the toilet's not facing me.
It's on the left and it's facing to the right. Okay.
So I have already worked out that I'm going to take off my pants
and I'm going to do a spin move and,
and sit on the toilet. And as I'm sitting on the toilet,
I'm going to let loose. Okay.
So I see that as soon as I see the toilet, the plan is because you know,
when you see a toilet and you got to go, you're going to go, right?
So I decide that, Oh, it's coming out.
I do a even quicker spin move and like a
Gatling gun.
It just rather that pap pap hits all the side of the wall.
[Inaudible].
Those guns that with the circles, you know, [inaudible].
Like that.
Trying to get the predator. And it just covers the
and I sit on the toilet. Most of it gets in the toilet and I just go.
Uh.
And I never felt better, dude relief, bro.
And then I cleaned it up and that was the most.
I'm just.
Dude. It was the worst. It was the worst office. So good.
When you go doesn't it, it feels like whoever you voted for,
for president one, that's what it feels like.
You're just like, Oh, make America great again.